our mission is to destroy a battery of
AAA guns that shooting down our bombers
but we have to push through enemy
territory and take out those guns before
crop reinforcements arrive
[Music]
everybody welcome to Gamescom 2017 I'm
Dave joined by Oscar we played a little
bit of the new Call of Duty World War 2
now the biggest point that everyone's
know about is the new mode war you get
some label play some war absolutely I
did get to play some role a good time
doing some more what do you make of it I
really enjoyed it actually
it felt like it felt different to how
Call of Duty of Bill yeah has been for a
few years now it felt like you were
actually doing something rather than
just running around like a headless
chicken trying to shoot whatever came in
front of you felt like there was an
objective to go and do and that
objective change right so like the first
one yeah I never actually completed it
seemed quite difficult yes yeah
khadija who's always tried to add
objective based gameplay with domination
and things like that but this is the
first time where it's it's really been
focused and like you're saying there is
something to do the first objective you
had if you're Americans you're
assaulting a mansion house you have to
take and hold the HQ then you have to
build a bridge which was very
interesting because yeah the enemy would
have liked gun points and good cover so
you'd have to use like smoke yeah that
which for me it was like it took my team
a few a few minutes to kind of realize
that because that's not really I suppose
this is a bit cliche but not really the
ecology players immediate mindset that's
something that if it's like a
battlefield player would normally go for
yeah at this point ecology is so ladies
engrained into my muscle memory right I
was just by shoe
hammering square trying to respond and
like just running forward as quickly as
possible but then once you realize that
actually there's like one focal point
that we need to we need to build this
bridge and there's a lot of places they
can shoot us from we need to use smoke
grenades or we're just gonna get ripped
apart and once we realize that actually
changing to that class that had the
smoke grenades and everyone you need to
get out of that stubborn mindsets like
quit your sniper rifle down pick up a
class at exactly be useful and it did
feel like they'd learned a little bit
from bow friend I feel sorry because the
Third Point was like a rush mode we had
to actually plant a bomb yeah and yeah
it was it was very stripped down and I
think that actually added more than it
took away
definitely cuz you had all these classes
that could they were very specialized it
could help you complete one objective
and you have to switch but they also
took out the kills
yes so that obviously again focusing on
that that core objective and not making
it so that one person was at the back
sniping so they could get their drone
and then from their drone they get the
remote bombs and the artillery that was
really satisfying so for me I think if
I'm gonna play World War two that's
gonna be the mode that I play definitely
obviously we did play team deathmatch
domination things like that that's where
you we kind of got to play more with the
the new division system yeah so instead
of like normal classes we've there was
five divisions right yeah that's right
one of them infantryman airborne
Mountaineer armored there was one with a
shotgun hey you've got better memory
than Meeks like I remember any infantry
one is just like you know your average
Joe around around yeah your rifleman
airborne is your smg's armored is LMGs
mountain is awesome as well but what's
really interesting about that is that
the each division that you're trained in
has its own perk I guess yeah like
speciality yeah so like the the airborne
guy could attach the suppressor to his
SMG yeah
like the shotgun could have like
incendiary rounds yeah which felt
awesome somebody meant that your clip
was only like four shells rather than
eight but like each shot felt really
like lethal and like for that this one
of the first times I can remember a Call
of Duty game having a shotgun that felt
good because like shotguns a tradition
in ecology pretty much useless yeah but
this one felt really good and like even
in war mode as well like with it moving
up you have to change up your tactics
that goes for the guns as well like in
the sections where it is closer range
having that shotgun was really good but
yeah in team deathmatch I felt that
again it felt kind of different to how
previous Call of Duty's have felt or at
least the recent ones in the like in the
last sort of two or three or maybe even
for Call of Duty's even when you're
playing a team-based game like team
deathmatch
everyone's just playing for themselves
and running around over headless chicken
trying to shoot whatever comes first
whereas in World War two it felt like to
me at least it felt like you were
actually you had an end the
you're attacking two wars their end and
yeah you could if you went too far
swap over yeah at least it felt like I
know it felt like you were a team moving
up slowly I mean rather than playing
every man for himself
yeah III will agree with you on that I
did again its cocking back to that hole
dialing it back the whole thing as
they've dialed things back they've
actually added more from it was previous
suppose you I play I think was advanced
warfare there was there's a double jumps
and wall running that was too much for
me sure and you know like me like many
other players have been I'm wanting that
cure world water experience which is
what they've done they've learned a lot
of things with attachments and perks and
balance and pace they've added that into
like Call of Duty 3 he feels like yeah
it does feel more pure more simple and
shipped back and I think it's better for
it as well and it's still got those
classic ecology things where you'd
actually I couldn't believe I was
getting drop shot like a 5s then people
with SMGs were just lying down in front
of me I might drop showing anybody in
newbs
drop there's no camera nicely there's no
campaign but they do hold drop shots a
house right I think I can forgive it for
that that's more player base as you're
the game's fault yeah but I mean team
deathmatch domination I say yeah these
are cool but I think war really so ups
me I'm definitely I'm very much an
objective bass player but hey we'll get
some more gameplay coming after you guys
soon so make sure you subscribe and
check that out I'm sure like the video
all that good stuff make sure you stay
tuned for everything coming out of games
from 2017